some of the places we're planning on
performing this next year
um we're talking about going to germany
we're talking about going to bulgaria
and india india is on the list of new
places we're going to visit and i'm
excited about india you know when i was
telling people in england that we're
going to
you know to india i had indian people
telling me oh they're
it's going to be amazing when you go
there you're going to enjoy it you're
going to love it it's amazing
and i just stare and the guy goes boy
staring i go because
your voice doesn't match the oh you
think we all sound like i'm sorry
i live in america indians over there
keep it real
[Laughter]
i'm sorry and i have nothing but love
and respect for indian people i'm going
to tell you something right now
indian people in the united states are
the hardest
working people i have ever seen and
that's coming from a mexican okay
and i'll tell you why i say this you
will never see an indian person with a
sign
that says we'll work for food in the
united states and you will never see an
indian person committing a crazy crime
like when was the last time you heard of
indians robbing a bank
everybody i can't remember bro because
it doesn't happen
first of all indian people are so nice
and they're so sweet
and i can't see it you know you're going
to rob a bank you need authority you
need to come in their guns blazing
i said get your ass on the ground
now i can't imagine would you please
take the money
why are you laughing i am
talking to you
forget this i'm out of here i don't need
this
he gets in the car his partner's waiting
for him
did you get the money they would not
give me the money
did you show them the gun i showed up
the gun
we better leave they're going to call
the police they're still laughing
where did you get the computer they
thought i was tech support
you guys should embrace this hilarious
accent that you've been bestowed
i think you mean sexy but yes i don't
know if it's sexy
son can you give me some sexy talking in
indian accents
[Music]
would you like to see the cobra
no give me something good give me
something good who is your daddy
tell me
meet me
okay wait more talking dirty more
talking dirty okay listen
what if what if you want to um what if
what if you want to
have intercourse from behind how would
you say
how would you say to a girl like yo
that's how i'm gonna have sex with you
what will you say
let me hit it from the back hey
hey
[Laughter]
my girl was here she actually killed
unwrap your clothing
[Music]
i'm going to penetrate you
[Laughter]
i'm a hairy dude right i'll say that
right now and a lot of you and your
husband
ew see that's because the media put that
in your head if this was the 70s and i
was hairy i'd be the man
i was with this one chick she was in her
early 20s i took off my shirt
she saw the hair on my body and got mad
she literally looked at me like oh
you're gross
have you ever felt your penis invert
before have you ever had that feeling
i literally had to sit down and pee for
a month it was awkward
i got a hairy chest it's okay if you
have a hairy chest be proud of it i'll
admit i do do one thing
a little extra that maybe you agree with
or don't i don't care but i do it
i i give myself like a body fade
i do it's clippers i start here
with a zero and a one
two three it's nice it's very gradual
it's very looks like i got a receding
ball line or something it's very
it's right now it's right today why are
you acting like i'm the only guy in here
who's ever shaved his package
why why why is this happening
you shave it buddy it's not gonna be
like you're damn right i do
and the real reason to be honest with
you i shave down there to make my thing
look
bigger because i'll be honest with you
god wasn't kind of the indian man you
know he gave us a lot of things he was
like all right here's what's gonna
happen indians
you're gonna be great with computers
okay you'll be able to survive in the
worst human conditions imaginable
okay you'll be able to leave those
conditions go anywhere in the world and
become successful
fantastic and what about penises
sorry buddy average
then he called the black people over
come here for a minute i want to talk to
you
listen people are going to be messing
with you for hundreds of years
here's a little extra penis i haven't
worried about it i took it from the
indians it's okay
i'll never use indian people just
wouldn't they just don't have the
dangerous sound to them
it's always got to be it's got to be the
classic scene in the movie you know it's
got to be the united nations gathered
around the table
then on the big screen comes that
terrorist announcement this system runs
in
sir sir it's a message from the
terrorist boris
and they switch on the screen pew and
then boris comes on
hello united nations
it is
i have placed bombs all over the world
in major city
and if you don't pay me 1 billion us
dollar i will
make world goku boom
you've got one hour that's with you
what are we going to do what are we
going to do they'll be scrambling for
the money they'd be oh what are we going
to do we'd never have an indian guy
doing that
just wouldn't be the same assistant
running it's the room
sir sir it's the infamous terrorist
rachaesh
let's switch on the big screen and there
he'd be
is it on
okay hello
hello you and hello namaste namaste
namaste oli uncle auntie
pleasure pleasure my name is rajesh
and i have placed bombs strategically
all over the world
now if y'all don't pay me one billion
dollar
u.s i will proceed
to make the entire world goku boom
they'll be like but but rajesh we don't
have money rajesh we don't have money as
the credit crunch
okay how much you got then
you